Let me give you an example of how your time bank
might work. Let's say, I'm looking for someone to fix my
bike. Well, by teaching design to other time bank members, I've
accumulated a credit of hours. I look, and I find Jane, who
is an excellent bike repair person, and I invite her to
my project. We agree on the job. The work is completed
and the bike is now running great. And so, we make
the transfer of hours which have been deducted from my account and
added to Jane's.
I'll bet some of you are already thinking
about how this works as a system. Well, there's
my screen, and then there's Jane's screen. And then,
there's some administrator at the bank. Even though this
is a more complex system. For this project, to
make it simple, we're just going to focus on a
single person's user interface and experience. What your screens
would look like, if you were using the bank.